echofon is the second under the Maltese
presidency and we have agreed on the
proposal aimed at closing down hybrid
mismatches with the tax systems of third
countries this directive is the latest
of a number of measures designed to
prevent tax avoidance by large campaigns
for hybrids regulatory capital the
council agreed on a carve-out from the
rules that will be limited in time for
the banking sector for financial traders
the Council on the delimited agreed on a
delimited approach more in line with the
OECD's own reports on bets on action to
which treats financial traders is
outside the scope of the hybrid
financial instrument rule rather than
eligible for a specific exemption at the
council we also agreed reached agreement
on this famous criterion 2.2 on how to
assess the jurisdictions in relation to
offshore structures but I would like to
underline there is no list its present
whatsoever what we have is a number of
letters being sent to a number of
jurisdictions asking them to engage with
the EU in order to start discussions on
budget we welcomes a positive
recommendation of the council with
respect of the implementation of
discharge of 2015 but lately and we
broadly shared priorities underlying the
2018 budget guidelines agreed today by
the council those being supporting the
recovery in Europe addressing
humanitarian and security challenges
both was in on outside the EU borders
and honoring commitments made under
current and previous programming periods